if you've been following along with this series
and you've ever wondered why it's
taking me over a week
to deep clean my entire kitchen
this is why
this is how I left it last night
and this is how we're looking this morning
granted I did have my nephew and niece
staying alongside my own three children
but still I'm literally pushing 💩 up hill here
I feel like every day
I've been showing up in this kitchen and
taking one step forward & 10 steps back
but that's okay
it's not like my sanity is hinging
on the progress that I make
in this room or anything
So quick backstory
I've decided that this month is gonna be the
ultimate reset month for me
getting around to all the jobs that have been on my to do list
and I am deep cleaning
deep cluttering and organising every space in the main area of my home
I started off with the bathroom
we have one bathroom
which we're sharing at the moment between five of us
and that took me hours
hours and hours
but it was worth it because now we have
some systems and some organisation
and then I set my sights on the kitchen
I started with the fridge
and I did that one afternoon
the next day
all I managed to do was the freezer
the day after that
I deep cleaned the pantry and pulled everything out
and the following day
I managed to restock and put it all back together
the day after that
I deep cleaned the exterior of this kitchen
and that involved taking everything off
every surface
and then steaming it within an inch of its life
we're on the home stretch now
because the only task left to do is to clean out
20 drawers and a cupboard
then put them all back together again
so you know
not that much
and how am I feeling emotionally?
thank you so much for asking
well last night
those five kids just would not go to sleep
for the life of me
so I'm feeling quite tired
I'm also feeling like
I'm really looking forward to the school term starting again
they've been on holidays for 36 days
and we've got 15 more to go
not that I've been counting or anything
and I'm also getting pretty sick of just standing here in this kitchen
if I'm honest
so I've decided
come hell or high water
we are getting this job completed today
to set the scene for you
it's a really hot day here in Aotearoa
New Zealand and currently
all I can hear is the beautiful songs of native birds,
cicadas and the whooping and hollering of
my brother and my husband
who are two different people by the way
while they're playing outside
carefree in the pool with the kids
and all I can think is
I'm standing in this hot kitchen with my sore feet
sweating my non existent 🍒 off
you bastards
I'm mostly joking
but also how nice would it be to be a dad for just like one day
anyway inevitably
somebody's gonna tell me that my drawers are really full
and I have a lot of stuff and like
you're not wrong
but also this kitchen is smaller than my last
so we built this little cabinet
and today I'm gonna finally stock her
but first I'm gonna have a little sit down
because I'm literally cooking
When restocking the glasses
I realised just how many have been broken lately
We’ve hosted a lot lately
and I feel like every time people come over
something gets broken
but I didn't realise just how many until I restocked that drawer
so I'm definitely gonna add “buy cute glasses”
to my list of things to do
question
do all of your mugs match each other?
or have you got an eclectic mix like me?
I kinda like that
they're all different though
because I can pick any of those up and tell your story about it
like there's one mug in there that my husband had as a baby
and there's another mug in there that I bought 12 years ago
when my first baby was a baby
and that's why I can't part with them
because they're sentimental
I like things that have stories
I actually just like stories in general
I'll tell you another story
so that you're not too worried about me standing in this
hot kitchen all day
because full transparency
this whole day did take me about seven hours
so when I was about halfway through
I decided I was really hungry
and so I made a sandwich
but we had absolutely no bench space right
all of the stuff that I pulled out of the drawers
immediately went onto the bench
so I had to make a hand sandwich
not to be confused with a ham sandwich
but a hand sandwich is a sandwich that you
have to make and hold in one hand
holding it and building it
and eating it
and I was making such a mess
but oh my goodness
that sandwich was the best sandwich I think I've ever had
she hit the spot
and then I snuck away and put my togs on
and I say snuck away
because those three kids I mentioned
if they see me in my togs
you are guaranteed that they are gonna
wanna hop in the pool with me
and this sounds kind of selfish
and I don't mean it to be
but honestly
I was so hot and bothered
I just needed a minute
I needed to cool my core
temperature down
decompress and be left the hell alone
so I stole a minute for a solo swim and my God
it was amazing
but then when I got back
the taragon decided to test me
so that was fun anyway
so I'm trying to label
all of these little jars right
and I'm debating whether or not to tell you this
because it's quite embarrassing
but also it's real life so go on
so I've had these little jars
for over 3 years
and I have never labelled them 🙈
so when I'm cooking
I just rifle
throw and sniff them all until I find the
one that I'm looking for 🙈🙈
and it is not an effective workflow
so I'm so pleased that their job is finally done
you're allowed to judge me
it's fine I'm judging
on the topic of labels
somebody commented on my label making video that they were
concerned that I put the labels
on the bottom
and that I wouldn't be able to see them
but I can see them on the bottom in the pantry
just not in the spice drawer
which is why I labelled
them on the lid
so that when I open it
I know what the fkn I'm cooking with
oh my goodness
I think we're done
and I'm so happy with how this cabinet turned out
Got my fancy plates
fancy glasses
and some servingware
alongside my cleaning stuff
because they don't fit in the drawer
and on this side
we've got a cocktail
making section
and my small appliances
so that I don't need to try and jam them into the drawer
and if you're like me
which I'm assuming that you are
if you watched
until this point
then I don't need to tell you how good this feeling is
just knowing
that every surface
has been sanitised
every cupboard
and every drawer has been organised
the pantry has been done
the freezer and it's not gonna last
obviously
but for right now
it has scratched my
brain in just the right way
I asked my husband to do the oven
because I thought he could do something
and looking at it now
I'm gonna have to do it again aren't I
and if you've made it to the end of my
longest ever TikTok
thank you for keeping me company
I fkn LOVE YOU 💕💕💕